[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got harley here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
thanks for having me pam it's great to
be on the show absolutely let's jump
right into your background
obviously you haven't been running
shopify forever uh so let's just start
kind of from the beginning where'd you
grow up and how did you get to
the president of business so born in
montreal in canada
uh grew up in south florida moved down
there when i was a kid and uh
ended up going to mcgill university when
i was 17 so i moved back to canada in
2001
and had no plan of becoming an
entrepreneur per se i was always
entrepreneurial but never really planned
to be an entrepreneur
2001 uh september i moved to canada my
parents are still in florida
and unfortunately stock market goes
sideways uh
everything goes really really sideways
for my family my parents lose everything
and mom calls and says your dad's not
around anymore we have no money
um you should come back down to south
florida and
i don't know if you've ever been to
montreal uh but it's just this amazing
city it's sort of like
you know it's it's this european enclave
in the middle of canada and it's just
amazing and interesting and i was 17 i
want to be about
i want to stay on my own so i tried my
hand at a couple different jobs i've
been teaching since i was a kid so i
dj'ed on weekends and i tried to sell
vacations
nothing really allowed me to subsidize
my income and help my mom and sisters
a friend of mine told me that mcgill
university spends a bunch of money
selling t-shirts or giving away t-shirts
and that
i should go to the t-shirt business i
knew nothing about the t-shirt business
but i thought that was a really
interesting idea montreal has this long
history
of t-shirts and the apparel industry and
i thought that i would be able to
kind of navigate that and ended up
starting this little t-shirt business
making t-shirts for universities uh sort
of the promotional products that they
sell in the bookstore and that they give
out in the orientations
and uh and ran that business all
throughout undergrad
a mentor of mine i had mentors that was
small we can talk a bit about that later
mentor of mine convinced me to go to law
school not become
a lawyer but to become a better
entrepreneur and this particular mentor
was teaching law
at the university of ottawa which is the
capital of canada and so i applied to
one law school uh in ottawa moved here
in 2005
and didn't have a friend or a family
member i didn't know anybody here i've
never even been to ottawa
but i came here for school and i started
asking
uh where the entrepreneurs hung out
those were sort of my tribe those are
the people that i always hung out with
and i want to sort of meet other
like-minded people and i was directed to
this
random coffee shop in ottawa uh where
five entrepreneurs hung out
every friday night and frankly they just
commiserated with each other they shared
best practices they
talked about things that they had
discovered about their businesses and
and i just joined up with that group and
one of the entrepreneurs
that was part of that group was toby now
this is 2005.
so toby uh a year earlier had wanted to
sell snowboards on the internet
and so in 2004 there were two ways to
sell something
on the internet one way uh was selling a
marketplace
like amazon or ebay or something like
that um
which although it was inexpensive it
didn't allow you to build your own brand
you were effectively renting customers
from those marketplaces you didn't have
a direct relationship with the end
consumer
but the other way to build a beautiful
scalable unique online store
it was really expensive at that time and
we're talking about like magento atg
hybris websphere these really big
investments and he didn't have that kind
of money
so like any good entrepreneur if you
don't like the two options you generate
a new option
and his new option was to write a piece
of software to sell these snowboards
and uh that was 2004 by 2005 he realized
that people actually
may really benefit and value the
software to sell their own products so
that the
snowboard business was a good idea but
the software behind that store business
may be a great idea
and that's around the time that i met
toby in 2005 and ended up becoming one
of shopify's
first merchants i took my b2b t-shirt
business
and turned into a b2c online t-shirt
retailer
and after i finished law school in
business school i called toby in 2009
and said
uh that piece of software that you had
built that you had written
gave me independence it helped me find
my life's work it was
effectively a superpower for an
entrepreneur
and i wanted other people to have that
same experience and that was about 11
years ago
how did the t-shirt business turn out uh
we shut it down
around this time i started at shopify i
found that fulfilling t-shirt orders
and in the early days of any company as
you you know it's you're kind of a swiss
army knife and so
i was sort of the first non-engineer at
shopify and so my my job was
do effectively everything that the small
handful of engineers don't want to do
and it just got too uh it just got too
busy so it's actually
i'm not gonna give it up because i know
you have a big audience and i don't want
everyone sort of ddosing my t-shirt shop
but it is still there
for nostalgic reasons uh but i no longer
sell t-shirts although
i am obsessed with t-shirts and hoodies
as as you and i have discussed in the
past
absolutely so where uh what we discussed
was uh you wear
black t-shirts and black hoodies uh i
have a black hoodie on because i pretty
much wear that every day as well
uh where did your obsession uh with
black teachers and black hoodies come
from
i always felt uh so i after law school i
i articled for 10 months which is
effectively the
the the process to get called to the bar
to become officially
a lawyer and the dress code at this law
firm it was a law firm in
in toronto uh was obviously you know a
suit soon tie every single day
and i always found it ironic that they
they were pushing this idea of wearing a
suit and tie every day because
most of the lawyers didn't look good it
looked like they were wearing their
dad's
jacket or the tie wasn't done up
properly the suit didn't fit well
but yet that's what they were dictating
that lawyers wear even though
lawyers didn't look very good and i
remember when i got to shopify
i just i wanted i wanted nothing to do
with the suit anymore because
the suit had this negative connotation
for me uh and i wanted something that i
think
to your point i know you believe this i
wanted to reduce the cognitive load of
selection
every single morning i wanted something
that looks good that feels good and so
um i ended up discovering and actually
meeting james purse
from james purse the brand and what i
loved about james person
from a product perspective was i'm not a
small
size i'm not a medium size i'm kind of
in the middle and james purse does a
zero one two three four five kind of
sizing
uh so he has sort of these half sizing
and then
i think a couple years maybe around 2013
or 14 i realized that wearing a t-shirt
during canadian winters just didn't work
i was just too cold so i found these
hoodies from a company called blue salt
which is a great entrepreneur uh lindy
who's out of malibu and she created
actually like machine washable cashmere
hoodies and uh so between jamespurs
t-shirts
and machine washable hoodies from blue
salt that's my wardrobe
uh well now you know where i'm gonna go
since we finished this up
uh let's talk a little bit about uh when
you first started
shopify um you understand that you're
building a business you understand that
you kind of have grand visions
did you guys ever think you could build
a 100 plus billion dollar business and
kind of
have it grow into what it's become today
you know i think shopify was incredibly
misunderstood for a very long time i
think we were
underestimated certainly but also
misunderstood you have to understand
that
um the market i remember some of the
early vcs that we met with when we were
first thinking of raising our series c
excuse me our series a uh well before
seriously our series a
would tell us that the market's just not
big enough that the total addressable
market
for e-commerce software was very very
small
and i think what a lot of folks missed
forget about shopify but just the
shopify market was that
the pie itself like we wanted a bigger
piece of the pie but we were also
expanding the pie itself
and that the market for folks that
wanted software that makes more than
cost was far bigger than any spreadsheet
would
would would describe so the idea
initially was
anyone that wants to sell something
online can and they can build a
beautiful online store for 29
and it's gonna be customized to their
brand it's gonna be scalable
it's gonna have all the things they they
they need um but it wasn't until
i think around 2014 2015 kind of you
know a year or two before the ipo
the people began to realize wait a
second this is this is different
what what shopify is doing is they're
trying to create
new entrepreneurs we're giving software
to existing entrepreneurs
and making sure they can run scale build
businesses more effectively
but we're also doing is we are expanding
the definition
and the pool of people that
self-identify as entrepreneurs
and uh and so no i i don't think people
understood it i think we knew that there
was something really special here it's
the reason why
um certainly toby and i but our team you
know this is our life's work this idea
you know every 52 seconds
this is interesting every 52 seconds a
brand new entrepreneur
gets their first sale on shopify and the
reason that i think is so interesting
is not i mean you hear us talk about
kylie jenner building a billion dollar
brand on shopify right or alberts or
bombas or tommy john
or fashion nova um or these you know kit
these amazing companies that have built
huge businesses
from their mom's kitchen table all on
shopify and never never had to leave and
never will leave
but it's those those merchants that make
that the first-time entrepreneurs
who commercialize their hobby who need
to make more money especially during a
pandemic
who hate their job and want to find a
way to self-actualize and be creative
and i think this idea that shopify has
become the entrepreneurship company
that is something that people are just
beginning to understand so when you
think of that
like there's the what i'll call
storefront which is just hey we give you
some software and you can set up a store
you can sell things on the internet
how else does that kind of manifest
itself are there other things that
you guys think go into that bucket of
just we're going to take individuals and
help them transition to self-identifying
as an entrepreneur and how that will
kind of show up in the software
yeah so if you sort of think of
uh the product of shopify in different
chapters chapter one was make it really
easy to open up an online store and
start selling to a global audience
and that was something that we knew was
needed we knew that folks
couldn't do it it was to expect you
either needed to be an engineer or you
need a lot of money
to build your own online store there's
some open source software when we got
started but
it was very very complicated and i get
while the marketplaces do play a role
you don't have a direct relationship
with that marketplace the marketplace
effectively is renting you these
customers and
and and so if you want to have a real
brand you want to build something
that's not a great solution either so
step one or chapter one was build an
online store
and then one of the things we began to
realize was that there are these things
that every single merchant needed when
they were starting an online store so
for example payments
uh so we created shopify payments i
think around 2012 2013
so that anyone who's starting on shopify
would immediately have a merchant
a merchant gateway a way to transact
credit cards
in real time uh and and the rates that
they would get
would uh would be better because we
would leverage our economies of scale
and then sort of the next chapter was
okay where else are people selling well
people are selling offline as well
and so the next product we brought out
was this the shopify point of sale
shopify retail
so you can sell an online store and an
offline store and it all feeds back in
one centralized back office
and then that has sort of evolved and
expanded to
what i what i think is and we don't
really use this term much but it's
worthwhile mentioning this idea of
shopify being
a retail operating system and where you
have this centralized back office where
you have your inventory
and you have your marketing tools and
you have your shipping and fulfillment
tools and you have reporting analytics
and everything you need to run the day
to day
and one major channel one major sort of
spoke is online store
one other spoke maybe offline but maybe
you also want to cross-sell on instagram
or facebook or uh pinterest or
um walmart or amazon who are also
channels of ours
and then what you if when you zoom out
what you realize is
the future of retail if you believe it's
retail everywhere which we do we think
the future retail is where
consumers want to purchase then what
we're trying to build is is we want to
connect
merchants and brands with consumers
wherever they might be and
along the way we've added things like
capital we've given out about a billion
dollars of capital to small businesses
we've added the shopify fulfillment
network which i know you you want to
talk about later which i'm happy to talk
about as well
we've added things like a shopify
balance which makes things like
cash management easier and and this just
continues and continues and so
what you end up with is that every pain
point that an entrepreneur may face
we're trying to reduce that we're trying
to uh level the playing field so that
someone that has a great idea
can become the next alberge or the next
bombus um and they can do so with ever
having without ever having to leave
shopify
yeah one of my favorite parts about the
entire company story is just this idea
that you guys continue to arm the rebels
right now you guys talk about it
and have really built it in the software
uh when you
think through that uh obviously one of
the elephants in the room is
amazon and they're this you know big
massive business that seems to be
dominating the world and people read all
these stats
and it was almost like you know shopify
was almost an afterthought for a while
but i think
over the last couple years people woke
up and to your point maybe it was a
misunderstanding
of what you were going after and then
two was a size
uh thing and now with that you're more
than a hundred billion dollar business
people start to say wait a second like
this is a massive business this market
is way bigger than we thought
uh and also the shopify platform is very
very compelling when compared to some of
his competitors so
how do you think about you know where
you pick the battles to fight against
competitors with whether it's amazon's
uh
you know fba whether it's like delivery
fulfillment there's just so many
different things that go into this
mission of arming the rebels and really
helping them be successful entrepreneurs
how do you just prioritize and decide
when to actually
go and work on something versus when
maybe uh it's just not a work a fight
worth fighting
yeah so right now as we sit here uh
shopify is the second largest online
checkout uh
in america um so amazon is the first
largest second would be shopify
that's pretty cool this is really cool
yeah i mean it's it's i mean i'm sort of
saying it like as if you could like as
if that's it's so normal
but but that is incredible now the
reason it's incredible is as follows
it is it's not a flex it isn't like look
how big we are
the reason that we're so proud of being
the second largest checkout
is because if you were to pretend for a
second that we were a retailer
we were a store when we would go to a
payment company or a shipping company or
any supplier in our in our
ecosystem in our universe as a retailer
we would have this massive economy of
scale we would walk in
with gusto and the confidence and
frankly the leverage
that the second largest retailer in
america would walk in with
but the difference is that we still do
that except we don't keep those
economies of scale for ourselves
so when we talk to payment companies or
capital companies or fulfillment
companies
we we want the same thing that they
would give the second largest retailer
but rather than um keeping those and
using those we
give those to every business that starts
on shopify and that means that
the moment you start on shopify the
access you have
to all the different things you need to
run your business you are getting them
at this incredible
scale because you're part of this you
know larger
platform this larger community of over a
million shopify stores
so the more scale we have the better
we can arm these rebels the better those
rebels can compete and
more of those you know uh what would
have been insurgents
can become really incredible incumbents
i mean it's
i don't know this for a fact but i
assume at some point in the nike
boardroom they're talking about gymshark
and they're talking about all birds um
that is amazing
think about that like those companies
did not exist six years ago
and now they are leaders in their
category that type of growth and scale
never happened in retail it took
generations for you to get that sort of
scale and now that's happening
very very quickly and we don't take any
credit for all birds success
or gymshark success but we've given the
tools so they can do so really quickly
really effectively and so that's sort of
the first part
the second part is all these
marketplaces and
and just you know on from shopify as a
merchant you could cross-sell directly
from the admin
on walmart or on amazon or on ebay or
certainly on all the social media
platforms
because that's where consumers are
that's where they're hanging out if this
was
100 years ago you would want to sell in
a town square that's where the baker
sold bread and that's where the cobblers
will choose that's where people
were hanging out but because consumers
are hanging on everywhere
the responsibility that shopify has to
to our merchants is to make sure they
can sell anywhere
but the reason that folks often sell on
some of these marketplaces beyond just
getting access
to that audience is because they don't
know how to get fulfillment on their own
so
they can use fba they don't necessarily
know exactly how to
get great rates on payments so they want
to use you know uh pay with amazon or
they want to use the one-click checkout
but all of that is now being made
available without needing to ship your
product
with someone else's brand on the box
like you would with fba
if you use a shopify fulfillment network
like let's say hedonist for example
you now have hedonous boxes that are
going out you still get economies of
scale
we're still shipping it on your behalf
but now your brand is what the consumer
is interacting with
and what we try to figure out is where
do we have an unfair advantage
um so capital is a great example small
businesses
notoriously have trouble getting capital
it's just
banks don't like to land small
businesses they don't have a lot of
assets they have a lot of collateral to
put down
and a lot of the banks don't have access
to information to make a smart
underwriting decision but we do we
understand the size
the value the health of each of those
businesses and so we can make much
better more effective underwriting
decisions which then gives these
merchants these loans and cash advances
they can spend on marketing
and on inventory and i think all that in
aggregate
and aggregated what you what you end up
with is um
a much more fair playing ground for
these dtc brands
these entrepreneurs to compete and um
and i think that that's what we're
seeing and
as we sort of finished black friday
cyber monday 2020 what we saw is
on the demand side consumers also change
how they're playing now
consumers voted with their wallets
unequivocally in the in q4 of 20
uh of 2020 we saw this during black
friday cyber monday and throughout the
holiday season that they would prefer to
buy
from independent businesses assuming
it's as convenient as
easy as pleasurable and it is one click
checkout
is now is now offered on shop with shop
pay the ability to fulfill properly we
can help with that
the ability to have a beautiful online
store we can help with that as well or
cross-sell on instagram we can help with
that too and i think what we're do what
we're talking about here is
probably some of the most exciting times
of retail of the last 100 years
are happening right now why do you think
the consumer uh kind of trend has
shifted is that something where
these independent brands are getting
better at marketing kind of customer
acquisition and they're going where
the consumers are is it something where
consumers are almost kind of silently
protesting and they don't want to go to
some of the
centralized uh marketplaces and they
want to go direct like
what's driving that shift that's very
interesting i think part of it is that
you know it just does something like you
know one click checkout
that a consumer may have been frustrated
a couple years ago that if i'm buying
off an independent store the checkout
takes i don't know
30 seconds or 60 seconds takes a full
minute whereas on some of the
marketplaces with one click checkout
it's much more convenient and so even
though they
know and they feel they want to support
those those independent businesses and
i think the way a lot of them think
about it is when i buy something from an
independent merchant an independent
entrepreneur
i am voting with my wallet for that
entrepreneur for that brand for that
product to exist in the world
and i think we all um at our core
want small businesses to exist in fact
you know we're in the middle of a
pandemic right now
and i think all of us agree that on the
other side of the pandemic
for our communities our cities our
places where we live to be interesting
to have culture we need independent
businesses to exist so we as humans i
think and consumers
want these things to happen but if it's
really inconvenient
we may not always make the right
decision we may decide to go buy it off
a big department store or a big
marketplace
but again shop pay or apple pay or
android pay
if you've ever used shot pay but shot
paid to me is the greatest way to check
out on the internet
it's not only fast and convenient and
safe it just it takes no time
it just it's it's a pleasure to use it's
quite
unbelievable and so as you begin to take
away
some of the value that those big
department stores or big marketplaces
have
and you replicate that and you give it
to the hands of the rebels
you see consumers shifting their buying
preferences
and the other thing is from a from a
brand perspective
there is a tension between some of the
marketplaces and the brands
they see a product that looks just like
theirs and it wasn't there a week ago
and why is it there now like they just
had some success in the marketplace and
now
they're being you know someone's
competing with them
there is we are merchant obsessed all we
care about is helping merchants and
i think a lot of the department stores
or or some of the marketplaces
have a very different obsession maybe
it's on the end consumer and so
they not that they don't care about the
merchant but the you know the primary
stakeholder for them is the end consumer
and i think we can still
handle make sure the end consumer has a
great experience but care about the
merchant
and then i think probably the final
point is i don't want everyone wearing
the exact same black hoodie i like the
fact that i can
browse amazing direct-to-consumer brands
and brands in general
and find something that is uniquely me
that fits me that looks good on me
that and i can support all the people
behind that business and that
i think is um i'm not sure cove had
changed that
but something is different now certainly
from the consumer side
where if possible i'm always going to
buy directly from an independent
business
that's a great perspective when you
started you literally did everything
that was non-engineering it sounds like
and today you obviously have many many
more employees and kind of entire
organizations
uh i'm a big believer that what you
spend time on is kind of a
prioritization
or a proxy for that prioritization how
do you spend your
day today like what does a normal day
look like for you across all of these
different products and orgs and
um you know kind of the now versus what
your guys are building in the future
yeah um the neat part of shopify is that
it feels so i've spent about a third of
my life at chaplain in my mid-30s i've
been here for 11 years
it's a long time and and i hope to stay
here the rest of my life it's just
it the mission of shopify which is to
democratize entrepreneurship to arm the
rebels to make commerce better
uh is is so the over the venn diagram
overlap with my own personal interest
is completely you know it's completely
overlapped and part of it
is you know i think entrepreneurship was
always a way
for folks to survive and now i think
it's a way for folks to survive and to
do something that is really
interesting and exciting to them and so
many of our my grandparents immigrated
to canada in the 50s
they didn't call themselves
entrepreneurs uh my grandfather started
a little
uh egg stand selling eggs at a farmer's
market because he needed
to survive and the idea that
entrepreneurship
should be accessible to everybody and
anyone that has a hobby
should consider commercializing that
hobby and anyone that has a passion
could consider but sharing that passion
with the world
um a lot of what i'm doing right now is
trying to tell that story is
is trying to ensure that more people
consider entrepreneurship and they may
not try it with shopify although more
and more people are
you know using shopify to start their
entrepreneurial journey
but i i i so right now it's a lot of
it's a lot of that i want people to
understand that entrepreneurship
is not complicated and it is not
expensive and is not out of reach that
it is accessible
and whether you sell two products a day
or two products a second you know
or you take your you know your youtube
channel like jeffree star did
and turn it into a shopify store and
completely disrupt
the cosmetic industry and you're
competing against sephora um
that's what that's what i'm excited
about i'm trying to spend a lot more of
my time right now
inviting more people into this idea that
entrepreneurship
um is this great way to to find your
life's work and
and to find independence in the past
though what's
because shopify is growing so fast it's
a little bit like the red queen race are
you familiar with that term
i am yeah so the neat part about
becoming like shopify is
because it's growing so fast if you
simply
as an individual grow as fast as shopify
there is no there's no delta
there is no alpha there is no way to
continue to do your job and to
re-qualify
and so what i love about shopify is that
over the over over the years
there's always this big interesting new
problem i get to solve in the early days
it was
how can we invite larger merchants to
come onto the platform with shopify plus
uh then it was okay well shopify's core
offering does what
most people need most of the time how do
we ensure our product has
everything that any merchant might need
no matter what vertical they're in
and that created the app store and the
shopify partner program the ipo was
something that
um was completely new to new to us new
to me
i'd never obviously taken a company
public i didn't even know what that was
and getting good at not only taking the
company public but then
running a publicly traded company and
not letting things like quarterly
earnings
be a distraction to the vision um there
is no shortage of those big challenges
and and the way that i sort of view
these challenges that i need to
re-qualify for my job every year
which means that i have to run faster
and grow faster than shopify does and
and that is incredibly difficult
and incredibly rewarding a little bit
about
covid and maybe not so much in what
changed for
merchants and for consumers but inside
of the organization
my guess is that you had to go remote
and so there's all sorts of things
around how do you continue to scale the
team
how do you continue to keep the company
culture just talk through kind of how
you as an operator
and some of the obstacles and
workarounds that you guys figured
out to make sure that the company kind
of stayed on the trajectory that it was
during covid that's a tough one
um that's a it's a it's a tablet it's um
when covet hit a couple things were
apparent to us
even in it even before cobot hit um
right now you and i are talking and
there's two squares
there's the pump square and the harley
square and we're next to each other and
it would be great if you and i were in
the same room together
we would feel the energy maybe there
would i would notice
particular body language or voice
inflection or i would you know there
would be nuances of the conversation
that would be difficult for me to pick
up right now but what was happening more
and more
was that when we were when i was joining
a meeting there would be three or four
squares
uh you know google hangout or zoom or
whatever and in one square
there'd be one person the second score
would be second person then another
square there'd be three people together
they'd be in the same location
that to me is the worst model so best
model
everyone's in the same room very
difficult to do that though when you're
you know
five six seven thousand people uh across
17 different
locations um so the best case is
everyone's same room the worst cases
some of people are in the same room
some people are not in the same room and
so we had already been feeling a little
bit like there there needs to be a
better model here which allows us to
continue growing
but scaling communication skill the way
we interact with each other
and then coven hit and we said look uh
we're gonna go digital by default which
doesn't mean we're never going back to
an office but it means that
shopify's office centricity is over
that going forward we will use offices
and leverage offices for things like
onboarding and planning and when we need
to get together
to do something really difficult and and
where being in person
really really matters but generally
we're going to be a digital by default
company
and kovid sort of accelerated that um
and as someone that is a you know power
extrovert um
that was really difficult for me i i
felt lonely i felt
my anxiety levels um i've had anxiety
since i was a kid and i
i've gotten pretty good at managing that
but my anxiety levels were dramatically
elevated
uh because i didn't feel that energy and
my wife's an entrepreneur as well and
and she was feeling that way too and so
uh it took a while to sort of
recalibrate on a personal level how i
can still get energy
how i can still connect with people in a
way that is
meaningful that is authentic even though
it may be digital
on the merchant side um we told everyone
i think it was like march
17th or march 18th 2020 uh throw out
your plans
for the year whatever you were planning
to do whatever your roadmap was
it doesn't matter the only thing that
matters is helping entrepreneurs
uh they use shopify survive and and and
get through this thing
and so within a couple days we extended
capital to we were just doing capital in
the us
extending capital uh to small businesses
in the uk in canada
we added a gift card functionality so
service-based businesses can also use
shopify
we recreated uh we we added
functionality to point-of-sale
so that anyone that had us in their
brick and mortar store can easily
transition
to a local pickup and and curbside
pickup and local delivery
so a bunch of stuff we did really really
quickly to get to get
um to help small businesses and
what i hope you know the the irish prime
ministers had this great i think his
irish prime minister uh he had said
during covert he said let the world see
that when when the world was at its
worst we were at our best
and i hope you know the legacy of
shopify
during covid was that we really you know
we not only
put out new products and really
developed functionality so that
entrepreneurs and small business could
survive this thing but we showed up as
the entrepreneurship company and that
that's my hope
of what you know what will be when
people look back on what we did that's
what they see
yeah i mean you guys did a fantastic job
uh from somebody who uh
you know kind of watched from the
sidelines it was absolutely amazing to
watch so
uh one thank you but also
congratulations uh you know on all that
success
uh i want to switch gears a little bit
and talk about uh something that a lot
of people who listen to this podcast
will
be interested in which is digital
currencies and kind of the digital
economy
um i've got this theory that you know
every local economy or kind of
nation-state economy has
uh their own commerce their own currency
uh their own regulations and you kind of
just go
through what makes an economy an economy
but it's all tied to
a a physical or analog space and a
geographic boundary
we're obviously watching kind of the
build out of a digital economy that
necessarily isn't tied to those
geographic spaces
and so if you think of what you guys
have built it's basically digital
storefronts and you could imagine kind
of a main street and you guys have been
a huge part of that
but there's also other elements to that
digital economy whether it's digital
currencies
um or other types of technology and so
just how do you see kind of the world
evolving and is this something where you
will continue not only to be you know
digital as default internally but also
it's just
how do we incorporate everything from
digital currencies to decentralized
technologies privacy-centric
technologies
um or just any thoughts there on that
like digital economy thesis
so november 2013
plus or minus one month but i'm pretty
sure i'm close to that
like 2013. we actually enabled
uh we enabled merchants uh to be able to
accept bitcoin
and uh that was early yeah it was early
that was definitely really and not just
that but
i actually remember the first store that
made a sale uh using crypto
and i don't know if the store still
exists i'm sure all of your listeners
will be
checking out but it was actually sms by
50.
it was 50 cents uh headphone store so
this is around the time where beats by
dre just came out
and i think there's a lot of attention
around combining you know celebrity
culture with hardware and stuff and so
beats comes out does really well and
then i think it was called sms by 50 or
i mean
i think that's what the name was and
they enabled uh
they enabled bitcoin and and so i i
don't
look uh it is not necessarily something
that a lot of people are using a lot of
consumers
it's not as if a lot of consumers are
using crypto or bitcoin to buy stuff
across all the shopify stores
but our merchants can accept it if they
want and and it's it's kind of neat
trivia to know that
uh 50 cent was one of the first guys to
do that but
our view like you know we're a member of
the dm association which is you know
sort of formerly known as
libra we believe in a world with more
choice more entrepreneurs
not fewer and um you know i think our
merchant's data
does not belong to shopify the way that
we view data is our merchant's data is
their data it belongs to them
they own it the only thing that we can
do is is
is give them insights based on that data
so they can make better decisions
um and i think that you know this idea
of trust is sort of at the core of
everything that we do
and it's a filter for every decision
that we make um but i think the rules of
the internet are changing i think
whether you look at advertising or data
collection
or currency as you brought up
entrepreneurs need to be ready and
shopify has a responsibility to make
sure entrepreneurs
have the very best tools to build
relationships with customers and so
you're seeing this with facebook's novi
and dm and apple's changes to the
advertising landscape
um so part of our responsibility as sort
of the guardians of the world's
entrepreneurs
is to make sure in the same way that you
know as soon as
instagram was uh was talking about
commerce we wanted to make sure that we
would be the launch partner for that
or when you know uh we heard that
walmart was going to open up their
marketplace for third-party sellers we
want to make sure that
that day merchants were able to go ahead
and cross them on walmart or
or apple pay was available um we
we feel the responsibility and the
weight on our shoulders that if
merchants are gonna put the trust in us
and gonna put their business
on shopify then the onus and the
responsibility is that
we have to always show up with the most
current ways to process
to do business to interact with
consumers and i think crypto will play a
role in that when it goes beyond just a
store of value and
you know you talk a lot about this and
and i i really like the way you think
about decentralization
and and crypto in general but our
responsibility is not to say
here's how to do it rather to give them
the tools that they
may want so they can make the best
decisions and that's the difference
between you know being a real platform
and and being an
aggregator yeah and how does that play
because i think that's a really
interesting way to look at it's like hey
we're going to basically build this
toolbox it's got a bunch of tools in it
you as the
operator meaning the the storefront or
the business owner
you can choose to use whatever you want
you want to accept bitcoin knock
yourself out if you want to accept us
dollars you know knock yourself out it's
kind of your choice
i think that that optionality is
obviously very valuable for a lot of
business owners
how do you think about some of the stuff
that we're seeing and i don't want to
get into specific examples but
um yeah there's all these questions now
about everything from
privacy to data to d platforming
and it just feels like um i'll say the
crowd and really that's just
a blanket term for people outside of
your company
everyone has an opinion right and some
of the opinions maybe you agree with
some of them you don't but just
how do you think about hearing the
opinion maybe but not necessarily always
um you know following what the opinion
is but also understanding that like
listening is a key part of it it just
feels like
as an operator of a large business
especially a platform business where
other people are relying on you
uh some of these responsibilities are
shifting a little bit so just
any thoughts on kind of how that's
evolved over the last you know maybe
even two three four five years
for us the the way we've always looked
at it is that
companies uh company culture company
decisions
are very much based on uh the people
that are making those decisions
and one way to ensure that you are
running a
scalable company that makes good
decisions is to systematize things
so years ago you know there may have
been particular stores on shopify that
some people liked and some people didn't
like and some people thought were
offensive and some things weren't
offensive and one and and one side loved
these stores and one side hated these
stores and vice versa
welcome to the internet that's that's
exactly right welcome to you know i mean
just go to
twitter or anything and and post
something that you think is completely
non-controversial
and you'll see how quickly con it is
controversial and so one of the things
that we
we did early on uh in the last couple
years not that early on but the last
couple years was we created this thing
called the aup
and it's a very simple document but a
very important document
it's the access accessible use policy
and what it does is it sets out a list
of things a list of terms
that are prohibited actions products um
uh connections to the you know the
owners of the store
uh it sets out what is prohibited on
shopify
and you know it you know one example it
prohibits the promotion or the support
of any organization
or any platform or any person that
threatens or condone violence
uh it's just an example of the aap and
then we have a team it's called trust
and safety
and they both do it manually but also
using great software
and and using machine learning they can
go through a thorough and rigorous
assessment to figure out which stores
contravene the aep
and it is not easy work by any means and
the team i think
that team in particular has a very
unique expertise that is of critical
value to shopify
but when a particular merchant or a
store crosses that line
and we can say objectively this
contravenes the aep
they're gone and that's that's the end
of it and i think one thing that a lot
of
companies are trying to avoid is is
systematizing it
it is nuanced and the aup probably you
know
one example i'll give you is is uh ghost
guns um
ghost guns if you if your policy your
your terms of service
are effectively a proxy for legality
and you rely on the law to dictate
what's allowed and what's not
the law doesn't catch up very quickly
the law is there's legislation
there's common law which is based on on
case law and precedent
so saying well you know if it's legal
we're going to allow it
is actually not that effective because
something like ghost guns come out and
all of a sudden there's this
new category of weapons that is not
technically against the law
but to us feels incredibly wrong it it
contravenes our iep
systematizing these things make it
easier and it's i'm not saying it's we
we did it perfectly or or our our system
is flawless
but it is the best way that we have
learned how to govern these type of
conversations these decisions
and it's made it easier for us to be as
objective as someone can be
yeah the one thing i'll add to this um
is i i don't think many people who have
uh don't haven't had the both the
pleasure and also the headache of
working inside a large tech company
that's scaling very quickly is
uh there's this understanding like
you're not going to get it 100 right 100
of the time
right and so it's you're going to try to
do the best you possibly can in every
single situation
but obviously there is going to be edge
cases and nuance
and all of that stuff and so but the
answer is the answer is don't not
try that's right the answer is it's
complicated so don't like i'm doing
nothing no the answer is to try to find
the system with the fewest amount of
trade-offs the system with the fewest
amount of flaws and it's never going to
be perfect
and then to look at that as a dynamic
system whereby you can add things they
come
you know we had legalization of cannabis
in canada uh two years ago
far well before other in most other
countries certainly before the us
on a federal national level that stuff
is nuanced and so there is a
way to create systems that get better
over time where you learn from
you know you you learn as and you watch
how laws are evolving and and that's
what we're doing it and i
i think it's again it's not a perfect
system but it gives us a framework for
making decisions that i think
um are are objective and people can
criticize but at least they understand
why we decided to to do something i
think that's uh
that's the best way to be um i've got
five questions that i want to kind of
run through in a lightning round and
you'll get to ask me one to finish up uh
the first two are shopify related
uh first being what is your favorite
customer story
like that one that just for whatever
reason it stuck with you over the years
and you're like you know this is amazing
this really kind of
embodies what we want to do at uh
shopify uh so i have a bias because
uh we have more than a million stores on
the platform but i i i personally know
and this is part of my job i personally
know a lot of our stores and i know
their
their origin story and and there are
particular merchants that i met when
they were just getting started and they
just
i don't know i it's it's it there's um
there's this paternal pride almost
and i mean maybe that sounds patronizing
but it's not meant to be
and one of those stores is uh one of
those entrepreneurs is ben francis i met
ben in 2012
he was delivering pizza at pizza hut in
the uk in london
and he's going to school and he didn't
like that
the apparel uh industry had not created
something for
uh just regular people going to the gym
not talking about
big dudes that really are you know
benching 800 pounds um
and he so he created a apparel brand
called called gymshark
and jim shark has now become one of the
greatest
brands on the planet in that industry
jim shark has become
an icon they are sort of the poster
child for
direct to consumer and for building a
brand from scratch and the best part is
the the thing that drives ben today is
the same thing he drove him then and he
did it with
authenticity and he's done it with grit
and he's done it with um
incredible uh uh sort of a commitment
to not only being a better leader every
year but also making sure the company
gets better
even the way they do with influencers i
find incredibly
sophisticated and smart and and so
watching ben's story all the way uh from
you know
literally dorm room to i i just came out
that
jim shark is now a billion more than a
billion dollar brand uh that was in the
uh that was in the media
in november so i can say that uh that is
like there's a twinkle in my eye uh
thinking about that story i'm incredibly
proud to watch
to see that so if i had to pick like one
business that
is super transparent digital first you
know kind of all the things that
uh uh shopify i think stands for
that probably would be near the top of
the list so it's pretty cool to hear you
kind of
uh talk about that one and for those who
haven't seen i think it was in november
when they made the
uh announcement about their evaluation
uh ben put out like a pretty cool
behind-the-scenes video really
explaining you know all the way down to
like here's how much i own the company
here's why i made certain decisions just
the transparency is
you know off the charts so yeah it's
really cool to see but something else
pump that i'd say to that is
the amount of there's people to really
talk about this so people talk about
investment yes i'm sure ben may have
invested a bunch of different companies
but the amount of of startups and brands
that have been inspired
by ben's story that have now gone on to
create their own
stories that flywheel effect of
entrepreneurship i mean that's what i'm
here for
that is is one of the most important
things that is not really well
documented or talked about
because it's it that is the infinite
game of all this that
more and more entrepreneurs are being
created and some of them are doing it
for money so when they're doing it
because
they want to be famous some of them are
doing it because they need to survive
and put food in the table
everyone on shopify's definition of
success is totally different
but the the the common thread is that
they've all utilized entrepreneurship
to find their version of success and ben
exemplifies that
i love it uh you've had the same
business partners
uh and people around you for a very long
time what's the importance of kind of
long-term partners
in your opinion context i think these
companies
uh like shopify and many others there
are so many
there's so many parts to it i mean if
you if shopify was
our capital business for example if it
was it's a standalone company it would
be one of the biggest capital businesses
on the planet uh our point of sale
company if it was a standalone
stand-alone point-of-sale company just
for brick and mortar it'd be one of the
largest point of sale companies on the
planet
so the there's so many different moving
parts to a business of our size
and we you know like black friday i
think we processed two billion dollars
worth of worth of gm
in one day i mean there was i think on a
per minute basis we were seeing about
1.1 or 1.2
million dollars a minute being pressed
on the platform having people that have
very very deep context is very very
valuable
however the caveat to it is you need to
also re-qualify for your job every year
and when you combine people that want to
requalify and do re-qualify
and also have very very deep context
you end up with a very very long tenure
and i used to sort of attribute that to
the canadian
thing that we're in canada and and
people are more loyal here i'd actually
think it's a canadian thing maybe it is
but but it's actually shopify i think
the average tenured shop is very very
long and part of it is that we look at
people's careers
as jungle gyms and not ladders and and
someone who's running a team may want to
go be an individual contributor
and someone who's in a contributor may
want to go ahead and run a fulfillment
network and
and we as long as you re-qualify um
i i we we want we want you to stick
around and that's been um something that
i'm really proud of about our company
and our team it's impressive
uh three more questions first up is the
more serious one what's the most
important book that you've ever read
ever read um probably high output
management by andy grove
uh i read it years ago but i've read it
probably again two years ago but that
would be
uh that would be the most important book
to run a company
um and um
what's another uh yeah i would say that
one's probably the way if you're gonna
give one book out it'd be that one
because i think that is just so
um it's prescient and it's so helpful to
run a business at any stage and
probably the hard things of heart about
hard things is kind of the the new
modern version of that because
i think that ben goes into detail about
that stuff too but i thought um
high output was just amazing it's a
classic for a reason
uh exactly second one is a little bit
more personal
uh our friend's over at eight sleep um
they've got this thermoregulation bed
that i've been sleeping on and i've
become fascinated with getting
better sleep uh what is your sleep
routine and how has that evolved over
time i'm sure
when you were the only non-engineer
employee you were scrambling around not
sleeping that much has it gotten better
or
kind of how do you think about sleep uh
i need to sleep seven or eight hours i
find that i'm a basket case when i don't
i
lindsey and i my wife and i have two
young children we have a two-year-old
zoe and a four-year-old
bailey and uh they don't sleep that well
and so that is kind of tricky
so the last couple weeks they the kids
have been really tricky and so
um my wife and i have been taking turns
waking up and and then
if i know that i have not had a really
good night's sleep i try not to have
back to back-to-back meetings during the
morning i try to sort of you know come
into the day
um but actually you know i i have pretty
high anxiety and like i mentioned
earlier i've learned how to manage it
one thing that i've done and it's become
almost you know almost common practice
in
tech and i think in sort of the
entrepreneurship space but meditation
has been one of the greatest things i've
ever done
um and i i i i'm religious about my
calendar i i diarize everything in my
calendar from
a walk with my wife to a five or ten
minute meditation
or mindfulness session and uh i think
sleep is incredibly important
and i i don't have any ritual then i
need pitch black one thing that i didn't
have
uh previously was we had blinds but they
never closed properly and then all i
didn't realize how much that affected me
and now i i shut the blinds and and it's
pitch black and that has been really
helpful
yeah it's uh it's crazy to hear once you
learn that
how important sleep is going backwards
to crazy sleeping a lot crazy
yeah i was the exact same way um and
because you because you you think of
like
you know there's sort of this culture in
the space that you and i are in where
it's you know
really like work work work work work and
that's everything and what i think you
actually
realize is if you want to do this over a
longer period of time again like
it's been a third of my life and i
wanted the rest of my life i need to
find a way to do this in a sustainable
way
that doesn't mean slowing down that
doesn't mean me getting lazy or
lethargic
it just means you know i i grabbed some
some some tea before the session because
i it's in the afternoon it's almost 3
p.m here
uh eastern time i want to make sure that
i bring my best to this
this discussion and i know that if i
drink coffee now i won't sleep well at
night but if i have half a glass of
matcha
it'll give me just this calm alertness
that i'm looking for i
could not agree more uh last question
you could ask me one to finish up
uh is more fun aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer
uh what's the it's called the fermi
paradox right uh i think it's what's
called
there's it's got to be something like
like where are they i i believe in the
fermi paradox that to me is is a paradox
i i i'm confused how we haven't find
them we haven't seen anybody
where the hell is everybody is sort of
the so i i think i subscribe to the
fermi paradox
uh philosophy um and and my question for
you
because i'm gonna flip this around is i
i'm certain that you've purchased off a
ton of different dtc brands whether
on shopify or not what is your favorite
independent brand
right now
i'm cheating because i know the founders
and i know their story and like there's
always this like emotional connection
when you know somebody's story so like
you know founders who are watching like
go tell your stories and uh you'll get
more customers and they'll stay with you
forever
uh but adam's uh shoes both uh welcast
and sidra uh
are two immigrants uh from pakistan
and they just have this ridiculous story
that like
you know anyone born in the western
world can't imagine like they didn't
know english they didn't have access to
the internet
you know they met their parents were
like no you can't hang out
and they come from these small villages
in pakistan and eventually amazing
not only kind of stay together not only
make it to the united states
but eventually start a company get
accepted into y combinator and you know
it's just like this crazy thing
um and i always say and and they know
who they are right i mean i just read an
article about them i think a week ago
where they put an ad that says we are i
think the ad is we are not cheap
something like that right yeah see that
yes right yes
and like we are we are we are we are not
we are not inexpensive or
something like that and i thought that
was what a clever thing to say because
what you're basically saying is
look this is not for everyone but for
the people that it is for
these will be great shoes these will be
shoes you will absolutely love and yes
the sticker price is 150 bucks
and yes that's expensive for a pair of
shoes however what you are buying is
something that you are going to value
and i think that is so damn important i
think they're a shopify merchant as well
uh so it's cool too cool for you to
reference that
for sure well listen you're doing a
fantastic job uh kind of not only
sharing i think the message of the
business but also just entrepreneurship
in general
and you know it's uh pretty interesting
to have this conversation after we
watched 2020 where
i think a lot of people just got
reminded you know that there's a lot of
stuff outside your control but
i think the one thing that the united
states canada and many kind of
capitalistic and uh and democracy driven
uh
um kind of areas in the world understand
is like the people who
want to uh kind of change their
situation they can do it through
entrepreneurship and that's kind of the
beauty of uh
of living in this part of the world so
yeah just beautifully said beautifully
said thank you so much for having me
pump i really appreciate it
for sure where can we send people to
find you on the internet uh harleyf on
twitter
harley on instagram uh there's the best
place to find me
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this let's do it again in the
future